and two days I'm going to be hiking the
trans Catalina Trail I'm running around
trying to get last-minute supplies I'm
excited for my trip but I'm also feeling
very anxious
because this is my first serious
backpacking trip I've had a hard time
this past year with some things in my
personal life and also with the death of
my grandpa who I was close with so I'm
doing this hike in hopes of clearing my
mind and letting go of some things I'm
also trying to do at least zero waste so
I'm gonna be packing all my food as much
as possible zero waste zero waste means
trying to send as little as possible to
landfill I did this a little last minute
and I had no gear to begin with so I
ended up spending four hundred fifty
nine dollars and seven cents back
packing is very expensive which is maybe
why it's taken me so long to try it I
spent 28 83 on all of this food and it's
gonna last me for three and a half days
these are my toiletries and look I was
able to shove it in this other tiny tin
I'm feeling very nervous my heart is
like in my chest right out I'm really
worried about the weight this is my pack
I'm gonna attempt to put it on for the
first time all right I'm gonna like tip
over as womenswear constantly told that
you know we can't do fill up and you
we can't do things alone you think I'm
gonna have a good time yeah because he
loved being alone this is like your idea
of like the best time ever
I'll be people will you I woke up before
my alarm I'm very ready I'm taking a
ferry to Catalina Island where I'll be
hiking along the trans Catalina Trail
the trails around 38 miles long and it
will take me about three and a half days
to finish
[Music]
I'm here and I'm going to the visitors
center to get my map I'm gonna be taking
a shuttle from Avalon to hey Russ to
shave a few miles off on my first day
because I am a experienced backpacker
there's a bison oh my goodness I'm ready
to start it's so excited I don't really
know how many miles I need to go or how
long it's gonna be I'm going to
blackjack campground it appears like I'm
starting 6:00
pretty sure I heard a rattlesnake it's
nice out here the paps very heavy what'd
I get myself into
well how I've done two miles which means
I've hardly done anything but he still
feel good about it
these hills are no joke I look at these
views oh it's so pretty here I'm gonna
stop for lunch you have to pack out all
of your trash so I salvaged this plastic
bag and I'm gonna be putting all my
trash in there drenched in sweat but I'm
staying hydrated I don't know how much
longer I have to go
I should pay better attention to the new
map I think I might be already at the
campsite I see some picnic tables so it
took me three hours and 20 minutes to
hike from hay press to blackjack I don't
know if I made a good time or bad time
I'm surprised at how early I got here
it's only 3:30 I guess I'll set up my
tent and hang out
[Music]
this is some curry lentil soup that's
pretty tasty day one is over I spent
half of the day being really excited and
the other half wondering why I would
ever do something like this I made a new
friend hung out by the fire so tomorrow
I'm going to be hiking from Black Jack
to Two Harbors and that's about 12 to 13
miles day two has begun it's raining a
little bit but not so bad I had my tea
and went number two I'm ready
yes missed yes can you believe this
cactus look at it look how good it looks
I've come upon a road and I think I'm
going the right way I looked at the map
but I'm not really sure I love snacks I
think this is my ideal climate no chance
of sunburn
just a nice hydrating mist I think I
went a minute or two the wrong way I'm
lost and I keep getting more lost and it
turns out I have a mediocre back freezer
more sighs oh I finally got back on the
truck I have six miles to Little Harbor
which is where I'll have lunch I got
tired I'm taking this little break
[Applause]
my back is really starting to hurt
particularly my left shoulder oh my god
there's so much weight on me feet with
his mud oh look it's the ocean we walked
from coast to coast Oh Matt Little
Harbour I found a dry bench to sit on
I'm eating some leftover oats from
breakfast for lunch
I have five or so more miles to go to
get to to harbors well be camping
tonight and I'm a little worried I lost
some time getting lost earlier I'm not
gonna make it by nightfall and refill my
water sack but not looking forward to
the extra weight feel like a hobbit
on a long journey except I don't have a
Mordor
whatup Ravens slow and steady up this
hill I'm wet but my feet aren't and
that's important I need like a Will
Smith inspirational Twitter video or
something because I'm ready to not be
walking up hills I didn't even know you
could get this muddy I think I see the
town what the head it's really raining
in him I'm struggling so close but yet
so far uh I finally made it I'm cooking
in the vegetable of my tent maybe it's a
fire hazard I am the luckiest girl I am
eating hot soup and I'm out of the rain
don't anyone tell me that this isn't the
most delicious feel okay I just slide
down for the first time and oh my god
my feet hurt and my body
but it's like a good it just feels good
to write down I had a pretty good sleep
I can hear the ocean
I'm really happy it's not raining this
morning everything is so damp still so
I'm hoping it'll dry off
yay Sun this is a little solar charger
and keeping on my pants so I can charge
my cameras there's some little folks
little plugs I just put on my pack my
shoulders are really sore from yesterday
my knees started to hurt but I think it
just needs to warm up I got to go to the
visitors center and pick up a key to get
firewood and water one in that person's
landing I got lost
apparently I love walking up hills I
don't need to walk up god damn it I went
the wrong way again I think I'm just
really fatigued this morning so I keep
making mistakes so I gotta watch out for
that it looks like that's where actually
the trail starts ok back on track so I
was originally gonna go from Two Harbors
up this way but the Visitor Center
recommended that I just go from here
along the coast because it's gonna be
too muddy in the interior it's not the
true trans Catalina trail but I'm ok
with that man with every step I was
having a sharp jolt of pain in my right
knee so first I was mad at my knee but
then I decided to think it and send it
love then I remembered this thing that
my grandma told me once which is that my
right foot goes out a bit when I walk
so then I tried to focus I'm keeping my
feet walking straight and it kind of
feels like riding with your left hand
but my knee does not hurt anymore I'm
really learning to listen to my body and
when my body's in pain instead of
getting angry at it I'm trying to listen
because it's trying to tell me something
and then sort of figure out what I can
do these views are just murdering my
heart I'm just so grateful for this
beauty and it just makes me want to
protect it and I know I could have done
better with my sustainable and no trash
efforts but I'm happy I tried am I gonna
talk to you that says sardine Queen
oh these feet hurt I think I'm in the
final stretched persons there's a lot of
mud and there's a big old hill that I
have to get up and it's kind of
triggering my knees stuff again but as
long as I keep my foot straight it
doesn't hurt really my knee is not like
going downhill so just taking it really
slow I'm like ten feet away from the
campsite but I just take a break re
welcome
it's a Parsons landing I think this is
my favorite campsite look the leaders
right there
so those are your alcohol swabs from
work great they taught me how to make
fire in nursing school
what's that stick again say uh parousia
rod hmm
[Music]
what did the dad Buffalo say to the son
Buffalo when he went to school what he
said bye son
I'm cozy and my tent and I can hear the
ocean waves
[Music]
it's the last day this was the most
fuel-efficient stove I was able to find
and I'm hoping I can get better
recommendation I have this whole beach
to myself and I'm enjoying my tini
it's 9:30 and I just have seven more
miles back to to harbors and then the
ferry home to La eating trail mix for
breakfast this morning there's another
beautiful misty day the cool thing about
doing this alone was that I was able to
completely set my own pace my out
thirty-five three more miles to go can
you hear the ceilings last mile mile
thirty-eight I did it my plaintive slash
mostly did the trans Catalina Trail what
I did do was backpack 32 miles with a
heavy pack and camped out three nights I
feel ready for the apocalypse I feel
great
like the sense of like self satisfaction
I had a lot of time to reflect on my
hike and I feel much more at ease so
what is even the point of walking for
miles and miles of a heavy backpack for
me it's doing something difficult on my
own terms so that when life gets
difficult which it does I know that I
have that strength to call on to endure
and persevere this is my final waste for
my trip I'm gonna have to throw away
these sardine cans these apple cores and
tea bags I'm going to compost and this
still has a lot of uses in it
unfortunately this is all the trash from
the gear that I got but I am going to
recycle it all I'm laughing a little bit
at my sob session I had yesterday at the
beauty of the trail but you know what
you can take drugs and get that feeling
a lot quicker or you can try backpacking
I brought TP but I haven't used any
because I've been air drying along the
trail and I've been doing more serious
things at the campsite bathrooms